♪♪♪
- Oh, what's up, everybody? Peace. My name is Bobbito
García, aka
Kool. Bob. Love.
Let's talk about what a point guard is.
♪♪♪
Excellence.
The leader on the floor.
The coach for the coach.
Let's elevate the title
to "point gods." The title that very few
have ever attained.
I'm talkin' about Dwayne "Pearl" Washington,
aka Pac-Man. And I'm talking about
[excitable screech] Shammgod.
[Excitable screech] Kenny Anderson.
[Excitable screech]
Future.
Speedy. Bone. Professor. Come on now.
All the point gods I just mentioned were
birthed here on the hallowed
asphalt of New York City.
[Car horns honking]
But let's go beyond
a Puerto Rico, the island of enchantment,
and recognize the point gods
de alla.
♪♪♪
There's
three players
who are kinda like los tres reyes.
It's a holiday in Puerto Rico.
You understand?
They already legendary on the island.
One had his number retired
on the national team.
He goes by the name of Carlito Arroyo.
Another recently retired as an NBA
champion.
His name? J.J. Barea.
And the
last but not least: The young one in the mix
who's about to create waves
and havoc in the NBA this upcoming season.
He goes by the name of Jose Alvarado.
And this is "The Point Gods
de Puerto Ricooo!" Point Gods. PR.
Let's talk.
- The end result,
I think nobody believed, you know,
the way it went down.
We scrimmaged USA at that summer before
the Olympics about three to four times.
And the one thing that Larry Brown that
was the coach for that team.
So they ask us to play,
you know, man-to-man
throughout the whole scrimmages
that we had.
So our coaching staff was like,
"We're going to play zone the whole game."
You know? So we had an advantage
as far as preparation
when it came down to playing USA.
But it was an amazing moment
for Puerto Rico basketball,
for the history of basketball
in our island.
To this day, they celebrate that day
like it's a birthday.
It was a team effort.
Everybody obviously did their part
for us to be able
to accomplish what we did
and we in the history books,
man. I'm truly honored
and blessed to be a part of that moment.
We played with a lot of respect,
a lot of dignity because,
you know, the fanbase
that we have in Puerto Rico is not only in
the island—it's all around the world.
Puerto Ricans,
they come out of everywhere, you know?
- Yeah.
- We got cousins and grandparents
and, you know, brothers everywhere.
So it's truly an honor to just
represent the island the way we did.
- So, J.J.,
this is one of my favorite moments
in NBA history.
I'm going to keep it 100 with you.
Because, and it's also historic,
not just for the league
but also for the franchise
that you represented for so many years,
the Dallas Mavericks. In 2011,
during the Finals and Game 4,
the coaching staff decides to change
the starting lineup and insert you.
That's crazy.
I mean, that might happen
in the middle of a season, rare
for the playoffs,
but unheard of for the Finals.
And the crazy thing is, after you started,
the Mavs didn't lose again.
Y'all won three in a row
and took the chip.
Where were you when the coach shared
with you that you're starting?
- Yeah, I was driving home from practice
the day before
the game. And Coach calls me and says,
"Hey, we're gonna start you tomorrow.
We're gonna change things up.
And all we want you to do is
grab the ball and attack the paint.
Try to find Dirk early."
Like, I go home and I told my parents, "Yo,
I'm starting tomorrow in the NBA Finals."
So I had to find a way to stay as relaxed
as possible, but it worked out.
So it was a great move by Coach.
It was not easy to make that move.
But he made it, and it worked out for us.
- So Jose, like,
you do something that's a little cuckoo.
You know, like, if I was a coach,
you would be driving me crazy.
Most people try to steal from behind in
the frontcourt on a fast break.
You do it in the backcourt on the inbound
or off of a change of possession.
- [Announcer:] Oh, from behind! Alvarado stole it.
- What were the sidelines,
what were your teammates, what were
your coaches telling you? Like,
I'm sure they didn't approve.
- I mean, it just happened naturally
when I was around, like, seventh
grade, eighth grade.
But I got in trouble for it for a while.
You know, they were telling me
you would not make any team doing that.
My college coach was like,
"If you do that, I'm subbing you out."
[Laughing]
- So I'm like. And in the NBA, coach
Willie Green really never said nothing to me.
I think he didn't know
I was doing it at first.
I think he was lost too.
I think he was just looking at up the floor,
so he couldn't really say
nothing at the time.
But when I did do it, I was already,
the ball was stolen.
So, he liked it.
He never told me nothing.
Never told me nothing about it.
- [Announcer:] And this is what Alvarado does.
- All right,
well, the whole world knows.
So it's something I'm gonna try to do
for the rest of my career.
- He did it in Puerto Rico
and cost us a three.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- Yup. Yes, you did.
Yes, you did.
- No.
- Yes, you did.
I'm gonna send you the clip.
- My thing right here,
I think I would have got Carlos and J.J.
with it. Carlos would've thought he was cool.
You know, he wanna do all
these fancy things.
- He'd be skippin' on the way down.
He'd be skippin' on the way down.
- He would've never got me.
He would've never got me.
- With his and-1s.
[Laughing]
- With my and-1s.